Secretary of State Rex Tillerson is in
Turkey for some of the most important
talk since he took office he's meeting
with the country's top leaders to
discuss the war against Isis among other
issues the two countries disagree on the
best approach to driving the terror
group from Syria Elizabeth Palmer is
following Tillerson Strip and she joins
us from Turkey's capital of Ankara
Elizabeth good morning good morning this
is one of the first official visits that
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson has
made turkey is clearly a priority and
the reason for that is evident it's not
only a fellow NATO ally it's an
absolutely crucial cooperating partner
in the fight against Isis in Syria
I think the exchange of views was very
helpful to both of us today Turkish
officials lost no time secretary
Tillison plunged into a series of
high-level talks with the president the
Prime Minister and the foreign ministry
and there was a lot to talk about
top of the list the war against Isis in
Syria on Turkey's southern border with
few soldiers of its own on the ground
the US has teamed up with local armed
groups including a Kurdish force called
the YPG but Turkey sees the YPG as a
bitter enemy in fact a terrorist group
and it's been leaning hard on the u.s.
to cut off its support but after today's
meetings Secretary Tillerson wouldn't
say the US was willing to do that what
we discussed today were options that are
available to us they're difficult
options let me be very frank these are
not easy decisions they're difficult
choices that have to be made and there's
another bone of contention this man
Fethullah Gulen a Turk currently living
in Pennsylvania
he's the spiritual leader of a huge
Islamic Network the Turkish government
blames him for organizing last year's
failed military coup and wants
us and him over so far the Justice
Department will only say it's studying
the evidence against him on both these
thorny issues turkey initially hopes the
new administration would see things its
way Salima Peru is an analyst with the
Economic Policy Research Institute
when President Trump got elected there
was a lot of Hope in Ankara that this
would change it now looks like that a
lot of that Hope has been dampened
secretary Tillison referred to today's
talks as an exchange of views that's
diplomatic speak for there was a lot of
listening there was some talking but no
deals were reached at the table and
certainly American policy wasn't changed
in any way that would be acceptable to
the Turks Gail thank you very much
Elizabeth Palmer reporting from Turkey